- Robert DuBois.
He's in prison
for putting Superman
in the ICU
with a kryptonite bullet.
- I'm not joining
your Suicide Squad.
- We'll see.
- My court date is coming up,
and Miss Waller said maybe
you could help me out.
- You're threatening
my daughter!
- Everyone stand down.
- Miss Waller, I don't--
- Stand down!
I wouldn't take
such extreme measures
if this mission weren't
more important
than you
could possibly imagine.
Are you in or out?
Good.
Let's meet your team.
Each member is chosen
for his or her own
completely unique set
of abilities.
- [scoffs]
- Hey, guys. Sorry I'm late.
Had to go number two.
- Good to know.
- Is this thing a dog?
- A dog?
What kind of dog do you
think it is, mate?
- I'm gonna go with
Afghan hound.
- Oh, my God!
Is it a werewolf?
- Yo, they sat me next
to a werewolf?
Yo, let me out!
- Hey, hey, hey!
He's not a werewolf, okay?
He's a weasel.
He's harmless.
I mean, he's not harmless.
He's killed 27 children,
but, you know...
- Your mission
is to destroy
every trace of something
known only as Project Starfish.
Any questions?
- "Starfish" is a slang term
for a butthole.
Think there's any connection?
- No.
- "No."
- All right.
Let's get it.
- [roars]
- This is suicide.
- Well, that's kinda our thing.
- I'm a superhero!
- That's my dad.
- I'm gonna get you
out of here alive.
- I'm going to get you
- Ratatouille,
what do you got?
- Bird.
- [pigeon coos]
- Nanaue! Stay off the comm.